the crime was committed against our
state borders the crime was committed
against the lives of our people the
crime was committed again the Dignity of
our women and men the crime was
committed against their values that make
you and me a community of the United
Nations
and Ukraine demands punishment for
trying to steal our territory punishment
for the murders of thousands of people
punishment for torches and humiliations
of women and men punishment for their
catastrophic turbulence that Russia
provoked with its illegal war and not
only for us ukrainians but for the whole
world for every nation that is
represented in this Hall of the U.N
General Assembly I'm speaking on behalf
of the state which is forced to defend
itself but has the formula for peace
I'm speaking to everyone who wants to
hear how to achieve peace I will present
a formula that can work not only for us
but for everyone who may find themselves
in similar circumstances as we did
it's a formula that punishes crime
protects life restores security and
territorial Integrity guarantees
security and provides determination
there are five
preconditions for peace
Dear Mr President of the general
assembly dear Secretary General of the
United Nations gear heads of states and
governments dear journalists nations of
the world
Ukraine wants peace Europe one space the
world wants peace and we have seen who
is the only one who wants War
there is only one
entity among all UN member states who
would say now if he could interrupt my
speech that he's happy with this war
with his word
but we will not let this entity Prevail
over us even though it's the largest
state in the world Ukraine showed
strands on the battlefield using its
right to self-defense in accordance with
article 51 of the U.N Charter and no one
will reproach us now or in the future
with weakness or inability to fight for
ourselves for our independence
we are achieving a result in this fight
and we see what the end of this war will
be and what will be the guarantees of a
stable peace
the U.N Charter proclaims the equality
of Nations and we proved that Ukraine is
equal among the equals the U.N Charter
protects the inviolability of borders
and we can form our state borderline by
expelling the occupiers outside
the U.N Charter
populates the value of Human Rights
dignity and life and we also stipulate
them with every Ukrainian City freed
from Russian occupation
we didn't provoke this war
we held 88 rounds of talks in various
formats to prevent this war just from
the beginning of my presidency until
February 24 this year but Russia instead
of stopping the crime of aggression
which it started back in 2014 turned it
into a full-scale invasion and we have
no choice but to defend ourselves we do
it we push the aggressor beyond the
internationally recognized border of the
Ukrainian state
and this is the first item of our peace
formula comprehensive item
punishment punishment for the crime of
aggression punishment for violation of
borders and territorial Integrity
punishment that must be in place until
the internationally recognized border is
restored until the aggression stops and
until the damages and losses for the war
are fully
compensated
there are four
sanctions against the aggressor are part
of the peace formal blocking the trade
and relations with the aggressor is a
part of the peace formula all this is a
punishment so long as the aggressor is a
party to decision making in the
international organization he must be
isolated from them at least until
aggression plus
rejects the right to vote deprive
delegation rights remove the right of
veto if it is a member of the UN
Security Council in order to punish the
aggressor within the institutions
we should in term a blind eye to
propagandhis who justify aggression but
apply a full package of personal
restriction against them
that is a punishment for lying
citizens of the aggressor stage
shouldn't be allowed to enjoy tourism or
shopping in the territory of those who
value peace but should be encouraged
through visa restrictions to fight
against the aggression of their own
state
punish for abetting the evil
a special tribunal should be created to
punish Russia for the crime of aggressor
against our state
this will become signal to all who would
be aggressors that they must value peace
or be brought to responsibility by the
world
we have prepared
precise steps to establish such Tribunal
they will be presented to all states
Ukraine will appeal to the U.N General
Assembly to support an international
compensation mechanism
we count on your support Russia should
pay for this war with its assets it's
also a punishment this is one of the
most terrible punishments for Russian
officials who value money above
everything else
the second item of the peace formula is
the protection of Life the most concrete
item now while the sessions of the
general assembly continue in the
Ukrainian town of izum Park region the
exclamation is underway of bodies from a
mass burial which happened when the
territory was controlled by Russian
troops the bodies of women and men
children and adults
civilians and soldiers were found there
445 Graves
there is a family
that died under the rubble of a house
after a Russian airstrike
father mother six and eight year old
girls grandparents
there is a man who was strangled with
the Rope there is a woman with broken
ribs and wounds on her body
there is a man who was castrated before
the murder
and this is not the first case
ask
please the representatives of Russia why
the Russian military are so obsessed
with castration what was done to them so
that they want to do this to others
the only thing
that differs the mass burial in a zoom
from what the wall saw in butcher is in
fact the burial
the Russian army was in the zoom for a
longer time
and therefore
the bodies of the killed people were
burned and not scattered on the streets
so how can we allow the Russian army
somewhere on Ukrainian soil knowing that
they are committing such mass murders
everywhere we cannot we must protect
life
the world must protect love every state
suffering the armed aggression needs the
opportunity to protect its Citizen and
liberate its territory
if it requires help with weapons or
shells they should be provided if you
need it
financial help for this it should be
given
if for this it's necessary to have
whether intelligence data just do it but
what's not needed is lies
we can return the Ukrainian flag to our
entire territory we can do it with the
force of arms but we need time
we tried to speed it up we tried to
implement the basic provisions of the
U.N Charter for Ukraine through
negotiations but Russia is afraid of
real negotiations and doesn't want to
fulfill any Fair International
obligations
it lies to everyone as it typical for
aggressors for terrorists even now when
Russia talks about negotiations it only
wants to slow down its Retreat Russia
wants to spend the winter on the
occupied territory of Ukraine and
prepare forces to attempt a new
offensive new butchers new exhumes
or at least it wants to prepare
fortifications on occupied land and
Carry Out military mobilization at home
we cannot agree to a delayed War because
it will be even hotter than the war now
for us
this is a word for life that is why we
need defense support weapons military
equipment and shelves
offensive weapons and long-range one is
enough to liberate Our Land
and defensive systems above all air
defense and we need financial support to
keep internal stability and fulfill
social obligation to our people
physical and social protection are two
elements of any nation's life so the
second item of our peace formula is the
protection of Life by all available
means Allowed by the UN Charter
the third item of our peace formula is
restoring security and territorial
Integrity look at how many elements of
Global Security Russia has undermined
with its War
Maritime safety food safety radiation
safety energy safety and safety from
weapons of mass destruction we are
already restoring Maritime safety and
food security and I thank Mr Antonio
Gutierrez for his personal involvement
Algeria Ethiopia Egypt Libya Kenya
Somalia Sudan Tunisia Bangladesh Israel
India Iran Yemen Cyprus China Korea
Lebanon turkey Belgium Bulgaria Greece
Island
Spain Italy Netherlands Germany Romania
and France have already received
Ukrainian agricultural products
and we have to increase the supply by
sea both under market conditions and
within the U.N food program for which
Ukraine is always a reliable partner
and by the way despite all the
difficulties caused by the war we
decided to provide humanitarian Aid to
Ethiopia and Somalia
so we will send them an additional
amount of our wheat but it's more
difficult with other security elements
on the eve of the general assembly
meeting Russia fired missiles at the
South Ukraine nuclear power plant the
explosion hit the station buildings
windows were broken walls were damaged
the Rockets exploded only 300 meters
from the walls of the reactors
and this is after the iaea's clear
appeal to Russia to stop any hostile
activity against any nuclear facilities
of Ukraine and in particular again
there's operation nuclear power station
the largest one in Europe which Russia
has turned into a Target
and that makes all of you a Target
Russian radiation blackmailing is
something that should concern each and
every one of you because none of you
will find a vaccine against radiation
sickness the cost of living crisis
continues in dozens of countries it
rules in the destabilization of the
energy Market it's necessary to remove
the main factor of global price
turbulence namely Russian energy
blackmailing it's necessary to cap the
prices at which Russia exports its
energy resources it's necessary to make
Russian oil and gas just ordinary Goods
again currently oil and gas are Russia's
energy weapons and that is why it
manipulates the markets so that
electricity gas Patrol and Diesel become
the privilege of you instead of being a
common goods available to all
limiting prices is
safeguarding the world this is the way
to restore energy and price security but
will the walls go for it or will it be
scared we'll be scared of Russian
threats it's necessary to take only one
strong step after which everything will
become clear the time has come for this
this step will put everything in place
after the Russian missiles rule after
the massacres after Murray open after
the burning of the Ukrainian prisoners
in Orlando by the Russian military after
blocking the force after the strikes of
the Russian tanks and missiles on
nuclear power plants and after threats
to use nuclear weapon which have become
the rule not the exception for Russian
propagandists
we must finally recognize Russia at the
state of sponsor of terrorism at all
levels in all countries that confess the
values of peace and protection of human
life legally politically if you don't
have a legal mechanism you can make a
political decision in the parliaments
this is the foundation for restoring
Global Security
if this strong step is taken doubts will
disappear whether to take other
important steps
and what is very sensitive in the border
the territorial Integrity when one
country tries to steal the territory of
another state it puts all of world
nation under attack Global Security
cannot be restored without restoring
that territorial Integrity of the nation
which suffered the armed aggression so
the third item of the Ukrainian peace
formula is the restoration of security
and territorial Integrity the fourth
item is security guarantees every nation
has the right to security guarantees not
only the legislation not only the most
fortunate ones we have proposals to
upgrade the security architecture for
Ukraine and for Europe and the world
which will not allow any more aggression
against us we are already presenting
them to Partners proposals for legally
binding multilateral and bilateral
treaties these are the conditions for
the guarantors to act and the timeline
for their actions to bring results
results on land at Sea and in the year
in diplomacy and politics in economy and
Finance in providing weapons and
intelligence each of you who will
receive the tax of our peace formula
will also see the details of what we
offer as security guarantees
I do not want to compare our offers with
the guarantees of any alliances that
exist on the planet now I want to stress
that it is always much better to
guarantee the security of a Nation
preventively rather than to stop a war
after it has already begun
and the fifth item of the Ukrainian
peace formula is a determination
something without which the other four
items will not work this is our
determination to fight this is the
determination of the pardons to help us
and also themselves and this is the
determination of the world to unite
around the one who fights against armed
aggression and to call to order the one
who threatens all so all five items of
our formula punishment for aggression
protection of Life restoration of
security and territorial Integrity
security guarantees and determination to
defend oneself this is the formula of
Crime and Punishment which is already
well known to Russia and this is the
formula of justice and Law and Order
that Russia has yet to learn as well as
any any potential aggressors
what is not in our formula neutrality
those who speak of neutrality when human
values and peace are under attack means
something else they talk about
indifference everyone for themselves
here is what they say they pretend to be
interested in each other's problems they
take care of each other formally they
sympathize only for protocol and that is
why they pretend to protect someone but
in reality they protect only their
vested interests this is what creates
the conditions for war this is what
needs to be corrected in order to create
conditions for peace
all you need is determination there was
a lot of talking about reforming the U.N
how did all and no result if you look
carefully at our peace formula you will
see that is implementation is already
becoming a de facto reform of the United
Nations our formula is universal and
unites the North and the South of the
world it calls for the world's majority
and encourages to expand the
representation of those who remind
this is an imbalance when Africa Latin
America most of Asia Central and Eastern
Europe comply with the right of Vita
that they themselves never had and this
is what Ukraine is talking about and
have you ever heard such words from
Russia but it's a permanent member of
the security Council for some reason for
what reason now Japan or Brazil no
turkey or India not Germany or Ukraine
the day will come when this will be
resolved
as for the talks between Ukraine and
Russia probably you have happened to
hear different Wars from Russia about
the talks as if they were ready for them
but they talk about the talks but
announce military mobilization they talk
about the talks but announced
pseudo-referendums in the occupied
territories of Ukraine what is true then
the military mobilization in Russia is
true
sham referendums are also true Russia
wants War it's true but Russia will not
be able to stop the cause of History
Mankind and international law are
stronger than one terrorist State Russia
will be forced to end this war the war
it has started I rule out that the
settlement can happen on a different
basis than the Ukrainian peace formula
their father the Russian Terror reaches
the less likely it's that anyone in the
world will agree to sit at one table
with them
and if my words will be followed by new
Russian missiles and acts of terrorism
it will only prove their weakness
Russia's
weakness it's inability to Prevail over
us its inability to prevent over the
world it will only prove that five items
of the Ukrainian peace formula must be
implemented as soon as possible we are
ready for peace but true honest and fair
peace that's why the world is on our
side
and finally I want to thank
101 countries that voted for my video
address to take place it was a vote not
only about the format
it was the world about principles only
seven countries voted against
Belarus Cuba North Korea Eritrea
Nicaragua Russia and Syria seven
seven who are afraid of the video
address
seven who respond to principles with a
red button
only seven one hundred and one and seven
France if this Coalition is against our
determination then I congratulate you
all because this means that peace will
prevail over any aggression and that
there is no obstacle for us to implement
the peace formula I thank you I thank
you for your attention once again I wish
you all peace